Yo, what's up  it's your roomie and I'm back. So, in this video
I'm going to talk to you about how I built a personal Chatbot for myself.
Yes, I built a Yoroomie Chatbot
How I've leveraged this Chatbot to scale my reach and build my brand as you probably noticed from the past videos
I'm not just a serial entrepreneur
I am a maker so I love building things and taking my ideas to MVP to launching them to getting feedback and
Turning them into revenue generating startups, or if I understand this not something people do not want and there
I'm going to charge money
I pay for simply shut it down also something that I would say and this is more recently which
Really is something that I enjoy is actually documenting the process sharing as much as I can about the process of going from
Idea to revenue generating startups
so
They're doing this the best way to do it is obviously through
Content. One of the recent builds that I did is our Chatbot which I'l link down here the previous video
I did on our Chatbot but I built our Chatbot in the open and really just
Kind of let everyone follow along. The feedback I got from it. It was amazing
People loved seeing me take an idea to Chatbot - literally generating thousands of messages
via this Chatbot and eventually turning this into something more than just an idea an initial kind of MVP, so
After I did this build I also really became
Convinced in the power of Chatbots. You know with Chatbots, I immediately saw how I could kind of
Leverage this conversational design that Chatbots have with other
Concepts and so I knew that I needed to then build another Chabot. Now, I was kind of thinking
You know, what should I build?
And I didn't really just want to build another standalone product that didn't kind of benefit everything
I was already doing and I'd also think you know thought about my
Personal kind of open content that I put out and my personal brand, and I just realized that
You know how beneficial it would be for me to build a you ever be chat line now one of the first reasons why I?
Thought this would be beneficial is because it's basically
social platforms consolidated into one
So everyone's like hey be omnipresent across all all social platforms and get your content
you know purposed across everything and I was just thinking like that's a lot to keep up with of course I tried to be
Omnipresent, but I really want one kind of one place to send one message in this route
You know the highest quality message
I could and it's make it easier for people to not have to like follow me on everything so I thought facebook Messenger would be
A perfect place to do this because I can kind of package up all the channels and all the content into this
Chatbot this would be ultimately ultimately the kind of centralized place where I would want to push people to
All right now
The other is it that I thought was the ability to control the narrative
So that's something when you know you have content across all the channels it can kind of become fragmented
And then the message can also become fragmented so having this one channel
would allow me to control what I wanted to tell people in that narrative and then ultimately how its received
Which of course is very beneficial when you're trying to get something out to people and then people add scale. The other
That I was thinking about which is a big benefit of having a personal Chatbot is
You know people spend all their time on Facebook like let's admit you and I both spend a ton of time on Facebook
And when you get that message someone messages you through Facebook, and you hear that Ding
You're gonna look at your phone most likely well at least probably over an email or a text message
I know I do personally so I just thought wow I mean what better way to reach people than where they spent all their time
Which is Facebook Messenger, which is where the Chatbot would be?
Accessible to people now that I kind of thought about the benefits of it. I was totally convinced all right
I just need to build this Chatbot. The process that I use to build my Yoroomie Chatbot was fairly straightforward
It kind of follows a lot of the other
process from my other side projects
but I first thought about
You know why I was building this and how this will be valuable for people and try to define that come up with this?
kind of Chatbot
And it was really first off just identifying the goal of just making a place where people can learn more about me
consume my content and
Contact me regarding
projects, or you know helping them out if they have any questions about this when I kind of
Have that down, then I needed to kind of go into okay?
All these channels that I just mentioned for instance all these medium articles
How do I then include those because they're already out there?
Their already  something that I get a ton of really good feedback on even these YouTube videos
So how do I then package them in my Chatbot because that's the best way you know to let people consume this content
Featured in there so what I came up with was actually a Yoroomie playbook
So I thought you know what does all the content cover?
And it's really about going from an idea to MVP to revenue-generating startup to scale and even some acquisitions
That I've had in the past so what better way to
Kind of package this up and make it easier for people to navigate and having a Yoroomie Playbook in my Chatbot
so that's actually what I did so I
repurposed a lot of medium articles in sequence in a playbook and also these videos in the Chatbot I'll screenshot here a
For the actual dashboard for Chatfuel so I did use Chatfuel and I used I actually took the "Our Chatbot"
Template and I repurposed it so I simply
Duplicated that to create the Yoroomie bot and then I simply modified using the blocks
The content that would be there, so on the screenshot here, you can see the Chatfuel dashboard
And it's actually my playbook, and then it's the about me ask a question, and then It's contact me or
And then after that is the actual kind of share
So there's a little reality effect in theirs that people could then message their other friends through messenger and share, so that's kind of basic
Template that. I you used in chat fuel so they're very
straightforward, so this took less than an hour honestly what it came down to is just getting all the existing content that I had
Already put out kind of packaging it up
Through this Chatbot you know just modifying the templates and then kind of testing that conversational interface and design
And just modifying it so I can make it kind of as natural and smooth as possible
based off of what people actually want to see
And would be interested in. After about an hour.
Maybe an hour at most I actually had this Yoroomie Chatbot live. What I did from that was I actually
Responded to some emails that I got from people asking me questions
And I pointed them towards the link for the Chatbot, and and you know just I said hey
I'm building this Chatbot. You know because I get a lot of questions that are similar to yours
Here's a direct answer to your question
But I would love if you could give me some feedback on this Chatbot that I just made by literally like 30 minutes ago
so I did that and
you know people were very receptive to that. It was only like five or six at first, but I got some really good feedback, so I
Made some improvements on that conversational flow
And now that's great so it's like my first kind of user feedback then from there
I followed a typical kind of launch framework that I take for products because this was and it is a kind of a product
It's just my chatbot for myself featuring my content packaged up as a playbook
but I then went to Botlist which I know I've mentioned Seth the founder of Botlist. He is
Amazing when it comes down to chatbots. He knows everything. Well his website
Botlist is a great place to take your Chatbot and get your first users
So I posted on, Yoroomie bot, on Botlist which I'll screenshot the profile here
But it got around 4,000 initial views
So I'm would say maybe a couple hundred users from that from people had actually tried it out
Got a few people to review it so it's kind of like an app store for Chatbots.
So it was a perfect place for me to launch from there
I've actually taken  created a bitly short link so I have a bit.ly slash
Yoroomie and that's actually my chatbot link so now instead of just having my website and all my content everywhere
I can actually link directly to my ChatBot and the benefit of that is people can obviously consume that content and
And you know find my playbook through there, but then when people when people use the Chatbot they can contact me
But they're also kind of a subscribed user so then when I come out with new content
I can actually push them a message
And they'll be the first to know through my chatbot
About this new content that I have coming out so I actually want to go into another video talking about now
After I've launched the Chatbot how effective Chatbots can be for sending messages
Versus sending emails, but I'm gonna keep this video short
You can expect another video coming up soon talking about that results, but so far
I've had some amazing feedback on it
And it seems to be actually adding value to people that do have questions and are interested in taking their idea to an MVP
To live--to revenue generating startup, so why don't you check it out? I'll link down here below the Chatbot but comment below
Let me know what you think give me some real honest feedback on it
And I definitely want to improve and hit subscribe so I keep making these videos. See you :)